اي نوع من التدخل تقصد استاذ طيب هل هل
نتحدث عن انتخابات هل نتحدث عن انه
الانتخابات هي هي بالفعل هي الحل الوحيد
للخروج من هذا الانسداد السياسي في ليبيا
حضرتك يعني اي تنافس على السلطه عاده ياخذ
منحنيين يعني مرحله
مسلح يعني
المنحنى السلمي والمنحنى السلمي ما فيش
يعني امامنا الانتخابات
واعتقد ان كل الاجتماعات الدوليه واراده
المجتمع الدولي وقرارات مجلس الامن ودول
الجوار ويعني كل اصدقائي ليبيا واحداها
سواء كان في الوطن العربي ولا في القاره
الافريقيه ولا في همم بحر الابيض المتوسط
كله بالحقيقه يعني همم يتطلعوا ان يشاهد
انتخابات في ليبيا وكان هذه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه او الانتخابات برلمانيه تنهي
حاله الانسداد وتخلي الشعب الليبي ينطلق
الى الامام